hello everyone and welcome back to round
three of the 2022 fiji candidates
tournament it is the clash you've all
been waiting for uh it is the chosen one
alireza firuja versus the streamer
candidate hikaru nakamura it is a wild
game you guys will enjoy this one uh so
let's dive straight into it alireza with
the white pieces opens with d4 and this
uh game is basically a story of how
uh
uh how uh to prepare for someone when
playing chess but the problem is even
when you out prepare someone in the
opening uh you still prepare for it for
for them because you know what they will
play but um
it is exactly that reason that they play
it did they most likely know the
positions that
can arise much much better than you uh
so maybe something to consider when
preparing for your own games i wouldn't
say that that goes for for the players
playing in the actual candidates
tournament but i've found this to be uh
true on on lower levels in chess so here
uh we have d4 by alireza knight to f6 by
hikaru c for e6 knight the c3 and the
bishop to b4 everyone's favorite nimzo
indian defense is on the board and queen
to c2 this is the classical variation uh
of course when the bishop captures on c3
we want to be able to capture with the
queen and not mess up our pawn structure
even though lately we've seen uh players
go back to the old lines where you just
challenge the bishop play b captures on
c3
and so on and the white having great
results with that but this is the
candidates tournament so
only uh the top engine lines are welcome
here so castles with a3 bishop
characters queen captures and now pawn
to d5 by hikaru uh bishop to g5 and now
d captures on c4 the noah variation uh
queen captures on c4 and now b6 this is
what black is always going for he wants
to uh develop this bishop with tempo as
the queen is on a on c4 rook to d1 and
now bishop to a6 by hikar we have queen
to a4
and bishop to h for now uh sorry h6 and
the bishop to h for now and here queen
to e7 uh we have knight to f3 and now
rook to d8 and this position is a
very very well known one uh hikaru plays
this with the black pieces pretty much
exclusively and he had this position
against pretty much everyone he had it
against uh la quang liam he had a
against rihanna rapper he had it against
shakhtar mahmud yarov he even had this
position against magnus carlsen and
hikaru did not have a problem in any uh
in any uh one of those games uh all of
those games ended in a draw so it's very
very interesting that uh alvireza chose
this line uh
to play in the candidates against hikaru
uh the problem is in in all of those
games e3 was played and this pretty much
uh
goes to a well-known draw online i will
show it because it's super fun bishop
captures on f1 rook captures now c5 you
have to play this d captures rook
captures on d1 with check queen captures
now we unpin pawn to g5 bishop to g3 and
we capture the pawn back with queen
captures on c3 queen d4 and now let's
say knight beat to d7 the queens can get
traded off captures captures and now
king e2 we bring the rook into the game
and uh
that is it it's a it's a very equal
position and a very well known one
however here alireza plays a move uh
that has never been played before in in
top tier competition and that is just
queen back to c2 and here hikaru uh
really started thinking uh as this is uh
most likely a position he has never seen
before or he saw it at some point
because obviously he was analyzing all
of those games he played against
uh all the the the uh before mentioned
players um
but maybe it's uh you know somewhere
deep behind in in all of the lines that
he he knows uh but uh the crucial idea
in all of these lines of the nimzo is
pawn to c5 so after some consideration
hikaru plays it and it is the strongest
move here so he has to make sure that e4
is not a problem for him uh bishop
captures on f1 rook captures on f1 and
now not waiting for e5 he first chases
away the bishop and this is what alireza
prepared for him knight captures on g5
he sacrifices a piece for the attack and
now you see that there might be some
problems here for hikaru the queen can
enter the attack easily the rook can be
shifted into attack very easily uh ken
alireza actually pulled this off so here
we have h characters and g5 bishop
characters and now uh he carl plays
knight to c6 fairly quickly he puts
pressure pressure on that d4 pawn but
alireza
plays the queen to c1 showing that he's
still well within his preparation uh
hence the the title greetings uh from uh
from stockfish uh something young
gustavson mentioned after queen to c1
was played i i liked it very much so i
decided to make the title of the video
and uh
uh basically uh uh after this at this
point in the game he uh alireza spent
maybe some five minutes on the clock and
hikaru spent uh already
like half an hour
and
how do you play this if you don't play
this queen to c1 there are of course
moves you can play e5 and this is the
move that everyone um
would play uh then knight captures on d5
on the four comes and after queen to c1
we can play queen to b7 this is how
black uh
gets out of this uh and uh now there's a
problem you don't get the capture on f6
because queen captures and g2 and now uh
your position is just uh terrible
there's uh no good way to play this with
white so instead alireza goes for this
queen to see one idea and now uh you can
see that the queen is coming to f4 then
the queen will be very close to the king
and rook is still coming to d3 to g3 can
hikaru survive this well
what can hikaru play here he goes for
rook captures on d4 uh but also uh e5 is
just a very very impressive move that we
have to show we have to basically show
uh in this position what happens if e5
what happens if knight captures on d4
and what happens if rook captures on d4
as all of the lines are really really
awesome so if e5 not allowing alireza to
push e5 we're gonna play bishop h4
prepare the infiltration of the queen
now comes rook the d6 adding another
defender here queen to g5 check king to
h7 and now after queen f5 check king to
g7 queen g5 check king to h7 this is
basically a draw yeah because okay if
you go go to f8 then we close the
position and it's still very very
unpleasant uh
for
for black even though black is up
material black is up a full piece this
is not something you want to play
especially against someone who prepared
this at home so instead after queen to
c1 like i said rook captures on d4 was
played but just to make sure uh knight
captures on d4 is fine let's uh explore
this we're gonna play queen to f4 and
now uh comes knight to f5 this is the
tricky idea uh the problem is if you
play queen to d6 the on pin also offer a
queen trade uh you just get destroyed
here queen captures rook captures and
now bishop captures on f6 and how are
you stopping uh just getting checkmated
here rook d3 rook h3 rook to h8
checkmate the this is a very well known
structure that always uh ends very very
poorly for black so uh you will not have
any uh good moves here even if knight b5
offering a rook trade we can just play
king e2 you know you still can't trade
rooks you can to double up here because
the bishop guards the d8 square uh and
even after king to h7 you can just play
g4 then h4 then you can you know push
the pawn all the way to g5 bring the
king to g for push the pawns all the way
uh this would be winning however you
play it uh so of course hikaru goes for
rook captures on d4 it is the cleanest
way to play this uh we have rook
captures by alireza knight captures and
now queen to f4 and here alireza barely
still spent any time on the clock it is
an hour and 50 minutes for alireza and
hikaru is uh well over an hour uh he has
45 minutes on the clock and he has to
decide how to play this there are a
couple of good options here uh knight to
c2 is the obvious one the other one is
queen to d7 which was not played in the
game but again it's such a brutal line
that i believe we have to show it
so you have to give back the knight at
some point you might as well do it now
but now after bishop captures an f6 yes
you are
almost getting checkmated but not quite
knight the c2 with check and now king to
e2 is the only move for alireza now
we're going to play queen to b5 with
check and after king to d2 we're going
to play queen captures on f1 grab this
rook and now the thing is after a queen
to g5 check you are not getting
checkmated king
faith queen to g7 check you're going to
play king t8 queen g8 check king the
seven queen captures here with trick
king to c6 now queen captures an e6 with
check king the b5 and now there are no
more useful checks so you might as well
pick up some material
but now you could uh well you could just
start grabbing with queen captures and
f2 but the best is a rook to f8 so
really really a complicated position uh
where white would most likely have to
settle for a draw but it just looks so
scary all of these pawns here with white
having uh
well
just a very very nice position for
example king a6 you're going to play e5
start pushing the pawn but now queen
captures on g2 and now the pawns also
start falling
you're definitely not winning this with
black but you might lose this with black
so hicaro decides against this queen to
d7 idea he plays knight's deceit to
check right away king to d1 and now
queen to d7 with check this is how he
gives back the piece uh so now king
captures and c2 has to be played you
have to settle for this knight not this
knight and now queen to a4 with check
ensuring the capture of the e4 pawn so
king to b1
uh queen captures an e4 with check queen
captures knight captures and now alireza
plays a bishop to f4 so even though uh
all of these moves have been played this
is already move 25 alireza immediately
plays bishop to f4 he doesn't uh go for
bishop to e3 which is the
uh the normal looking move uh showing
that he is still well within his
preparation he has an hour and 50
minutes on the clock and hikaru is down
to 28 minutes uh and now you could
consider uh start starting to push your
pawns and light squares because alireza
does have a dark square bishop or you
could start activating the rook but uh
hikaru first re-maneuvers the knight he
wants to bring the knights to d5
we have h4 by alireza and knight to d5
we have bishop to d2 nicely controlling
all of the squares that the knight can
use on this half of the board and now
pawn to f5 now he car starts playing a
little bit faster g3 king to f7 and rook
to h8 um
sorry f3 uh by white and rook to h8 and
now not allowing g4 because the h1 hangs
and if you play rook to h1 we're just
going to play rook to g8 putting
pressure on the g3 pawn so this is not
the way to go so all it is it plays
bishop to g5 first and now we have pawn
to c4 you could also play pawn to e5
just grabbing all of this space here
hikaru decides for pawn to c4 instead uh
and now uh again how do you continue uh
also instead of c4 sorry i forgot to
mention this f4 is incredibly uh
potent if you're not careful so it's a
pawn sacrifice but one that pretty much
solves all of your problems uh
uh because okay if bishop captures
you're just gonna capture everything it
didn't capture on h4 but if pawn
captures it's a temporary pawn sacrifice
but now the knight is the master of the
board knight e3 attacks the rook let's
say rookie one knight f5 now we're gonna
go after the pawn here if rook to h1
knight d for now we go after the f3 pawn
let's say h5 just a rook g8 uh we don't
care about the pawn and we've taken care
of the situation and the king said you
can even allow this pawn to be pushed
all the way uh let's take the c1 king to
g6 and we have everything taken care of
we can always capture here it's not a
problem uh it's just a very very cool
way to play this but okay like i said c4
was played in the game and now we have
pawn to g4 allowing this pawn push we
have b5 and rook to d1 now preparing to
capture here so uh hikar will not be
able to capture back as the knight would
hang so f captures and g4 f captures and
here pawn to a5 by hikaru uh alireza
still with over an hour on the clock and
he carved down to 15 minutes on the
clock and uh of course pawn to h5 well
it is a continuous pushing
and now comes rook to g8 by hikaru
giving alireza some very very good
chances here uh the way to play this uh
to you know
just to engine perfection is upon the b4
but that's usually the mood that you
have to play uh point is now okay would
you play let's say rook to f1 check king
to g7 now bishop to c1 we have to move
the bishop to start pushing our pawns
let's say b captures b captures now you
have this rook to b8 check very useful
king to c2 and now rook to b3 this is
how you can very easily infiltrate here
and if h6 check we're going to play king
to g6 if rook h1 king h7 and if g5 we're
going to play rook to g3 stopping pawn
to g6 because we would very gladly
sacrifice this to get the pawn to h7 so
this is also one way to play it uh so
getting rid of the b pawn so you can uh
make this uh
you know a round trick with the with the
rook but here rook the g8 attacking the
bishop uh and uh now comes rook to f1
with czech king the e8 uh and now uh
there comes a move that uh most likely
hikaru missed when he decided to go for
this line otherwise he most likely would
have gone for that b4 line uh that
allows alireza excellent winning chances
so feel free to pause the video and try
to spot this move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations uh on uh trying to
sacrifice the bishop and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is pawn to h6 that is the movie and now
you realize that okay you can't capture
the bishop so congratulations to
everyone who who figured this out if you
capture just h7 and you can't go here
and you can't go here white is just
getting a queen into the game so
obviously that's not good the other
thing you could do is place c3 it's a
another very nice line that we we could
explore just uh close everything up here
for example pawn to b4 a4 and now rook
the h8
and now we go king to c2 and now the
king will go all the way to b5 and it
will be it will be impossible uh to hold
this so instead after this h6 idea
hikaru plays rook to f8 uh offering a
rook trade and alireza has to decide
whether to trade rooks here or uh to
maybe uh play something else and it's uh
it's the greatest question ever asked in
this game uh so the point is if you uh
don't trade because in the game uh the
rooks were traded off let's say you play
rook to g1 you want to move the bishop
you want to start pushing the g pawn now
the king goes back king of seven now
bishop to d2 you are ready to start
pushing the pawn uh king to g6 you're
gonna play rook to e1 pressure the pawn
here uh rook to e8 it's still not easy
to win this rook to e5 you're gonna play
rook to e7 and now after bishop g5
chasing away the rook even rook to d7
because the pawn cannot cannot be
captured as the bishop would hang so
that's a problem bishop goes back we'll
just move the rook back so incredibly
incredibly complicated and difficult to
actually prove that you can win this so
uh instead after rook the fate alireza
said all right this this looks too good
to be true i'm just gonna capture and uh
will not now win this end game so king
captures and the bishop to d8 attacking
the a5 pawn pawn to a4 and now g5 this
is how alireza gets the the spawn push
so now you have to play king to f7 to
prevent g6 this is what hikaru does uh
h7 and now king to g7 we have g6 now of
course now you can't capture because we
just promote the pawn to a queen and uh
how do you how do you play this uh it's
it's incredibly complicated uh but
luckily uh this is already move41 time
control has been reached so he car
doesn't have to worry about um
losing on time and it's uh
well there is basically only one move
that
allows hikaru to survive this position
so you can even pause the video and try
to spot this one while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh not doing
anything weird like playing king to h8
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is pawn to c3 this is
what he carl played and this is the way
to go the problem is uh you don't really
have all that many moves here let's say
you play knight to the e3 looks like a
very reasonable move why wouldn't you
play this uh the problem is bishop f6
and uh hikaru resigns uh you guard the
h8 square and if the bishop is captured
you just bring a queen into the game so
c3 is the move you have to play uh once
again congratulations for finding this
even e5 uh if you've considered this and
i will show it because it's super fun uh
it will not be enough king to c2 let's
say king h8 we're gonna play king to d2
uh and after king to g7 you can't play
this because then of course knight f4
check will pick up the pawn uh but you
can play bishop g5 here just uh again
keep an eye on the knight and after king
they cheat king to e1 king to g7 and now
king to f2 king to h8 and now king to f3
that's how you play this king to g7 now
king to e4 and of course now you're
gonna start the gobbling up material and
win this so you have to go all the way
around but in the end you will reach
your destination so c3 the movie that he
car played is the the absolute best and
only move b captures on c3 alireza spent
a whole lot of time calculating this
because here uh i believe alireza
figured out that he
might not have winning chances in this
game after all and he spent also like
like uh an entire hour hour
calculating this move uh and he played b
captures on c3 and not knight captures
with check king c2 we have knight back
to d5 and now bishop to g5 and there is
quite a lot to calculate here because
you really have to play this to
perfection again
there is no good move here for black
there is only one move for black that
doesn't lose and uh it is of course pawn
to e5 without this move you are just
dead lost so he carl plays this now
comes king to d2 again you don't want to
play king to d3 the knight f4 check is
very strong
uh where uh you either trade the bishop
which isn't all that great because then
the white king will have to go after the
pawn uh it will be too far away from the
action and then just be before you
sacrifice the pawn and push the a pawn
to victory so instead king to d2 was
played now comes uh
king king to h8 and also yeah okay we
have to mention that uh maybe we don't
have to play this but maybe what about
something like bishop to c1 uh also
seems like a very good idea why not just
go after the pawn this way also seems
winning
knight f4 now is very strong again
because you don't have the bishop here
to go for this tactic that we've
discussed and now after bishop b2 knight
captures and g6 guards the e5 pawn uh
that's uh that's the problem so okay
instead uh king the d2 by alireza king
the h8 by hikaru now king the e1 and
again only one move that doesn't lose
for hikaru and hikaru plays it if you
play e4 here uh now bishop to c1 is just
uh game over the bishop comes to b2 and
you resign uh however after king d1 only
a move that doesn't lose is of course
pawn to b4 this is what he called plays
he creates a pass pawn of his own a
captures on b4 and now pawn to a3 we we
cannot waste time we have to force
alireza to bring the bishop all the way
back to b2 so bishop to c1 we're going
to play knight capture sun
b for now giving up this pawn but now we
have a very easy draw uh king to d2 uh
you could also capture the the pawn here
but then knight to d3 check or knight to
c to check can pick up the bishop but
still it's going to be a draw so instead
of king to d2 we have knight to d5 now
by hikaru and the bishop captures an a3
we have knight to f4 now going after the
pawn and now you don't have a good
continuation bishop b2 was played knight
captures with check bishop captures an
e5 but now the pawn is no longer
defended but also just knight captures
on e5 king to c3 king captures an h7 and
he was in this position on move 53 that
a draw by insufficient material occurred
on the board
and so the players each grab a half a
point so really really a powerful game
uh really an enjoyable one showing you
that uh
how well you can prepare for someone uh
but like i said in the beginning hikaru
had a disposition against all of these
amazing players against rapport against
the lacroix liam against mamijarov
against magnus carlsen and even though
alireza prepared this truly poisonous
queen to c2 line uh it was not enough to
throw hikaru off guard he he defended
perfectly and he played the game to
perfection uh from from middle game to
all of the complications to the end game
finding the only moves that don't lose
and uh well
very very very impressive stuff
uh alireza will not be happy i believe
with his game with the white pieces but
um
it it
you know the the the problem is this
queen to see to move uh no one no one
plays this and he carl of course knows
this position very well and he knows
that queen to c2 is a bad move or not a
bad one but just not giving white all
that uh
all that much so he only needs the
invest time to to find it and it was a
gamble alireza tried whether he car will
find it or you know maybe he will drop
too low with time that he will not be
able to finish the game but hikaru spent
spent his time wisely and he was able to
you know
just do all the work uh and you know
play play uh a perfect game basically
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna cover at least
one more game from round three and then
we are going to finally show the
standings i usually show the game
standings after three games have been
played in the tournament uh so that's uh
that's how we're going to do it later on
and maybe you know in the second half of
the of the candidates we're going to
show after every round but for now i
don't think it's necessary so yeah once
again i really hope you enjoyed it uh
really really
beautifully played by by both of them uh
i would like to thank andrew lostova
johan derek king aravind kumar vendeli
and for your contribution to my channel
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day